>> Announcer: Welcome to New York.
It is my profound pleasure to welcome Dr.
Susanna Grannis, author of Hope Amidst Despair.
I am very happy that she's here.
Reason why she was here is I was on the AIDS
walk this spring and I fell into the step
with a guy who was walking by himself as well
and we started talking about where we work.
Of course I gave him the Google spiel about
what you can say and what you can't say.
And he said, "Well, I work for this charity
and this charity does these things."
And what his charity does is go and help aid
children who are orphaned by the AIDS pandemic
in Africa grow up in strong communities.
And I was so moved by that I invited Dr. Grannis
who was the founder of this group to come
and speak to Google today.
Because I think it's very important as member
of the Google community to understand that
one person can affect change.
And we are in a unique position here at Google
to be considered leaders.
And with that, Dr. Grannis.
[applause]
>> Dr. Grannis: Thank you very much.
It's really an honor to be here.
For someone of my generation who spent much
of her life in academic world and doing publishing
and so forth, I was thinking this morning
about Google.
When I was an untenured assistant professor
in the University of Illinois in Chicago I
was under the gun to publish, I remember what
it was like when you went to get a book and
it was gone and there was no record of who
had it or an article was ripped off a journal.
Then later, after all these years later, sitting
in a small farm in Southern Vermont doing
research and discovering that Google was going
to help me find all kinds of things all over
the world.
It has been a great pleasure.
So I didn't put Google in my acknowledgments
but I want you to know that Google really
made a difference in the process of developing
this book Hope Amidst Despair.
I have some photographs and some, a few quotes
to give you from my book.
And it really begins with the despair part.
But be patient, it comes to the hope part.
This is a copy of the book.
And it came out and I've been writing on it
for some years, but really it started quite
a number of years ago when my husband and
I were Fulbright Professors at The University
of Namibia in 1996.
And during that time, nobody talked about
HIV AIDS.
But it was happening.
When we came back, I began to be concerned
about the children who were, who had lost
their parents.
What does it mean for children to be alone
especially in societies where you belong matters?
What happens to the children?
And so, in 2003, informally but then in 2004
more formally when we became a 501C, CHABHA
was born and we supported projects in Libya,
South Africa, Rwanda and Burundi and ultimately
focused on Rwanda and Burundi.
This book includes data from there are five
countries to compare to show that HIV AIDS
pandemic differs by country.
During those years, as I said it was spreading
and here is a photograph of how it was spreading
across Africa like wildfire.
To just to give you some specifics on that
in South Africa where data is kept more accurately,
recording the number of infected women in
prenatal clinics, in 1993, 4.3% of women were
found to be infected.
By 2005, that had grown to 30.2%.
Why was it growing in such a fast rate?
Well, one of the reasons, I think terrible
time.
Okay, good.
Excuse me.
One of the reasons is because of stigma, silence
and secrecy.
People didn't talk.
As soon as people realized that HIV was spreading,
the transmission occurred and had to do with
sex, they found it very, very difficult to
talk about it.
That silence and the secrets have also led
to stigma.
And stigma happens to youngsters particularly.
And this is one of several short quotes that
I have about stigma.
One of our youngsters whom I call Maria Teresa
said, "My uncle sometimes is like embarrassing
me, shaming me.
You must have AIDS.
Your mother died of it.
When he talks like that, I don't know what
to do.
I feel it in my heart."
Another, a boy of 13 said "I don't tell people
I'm infected, because they would stigmatize
me.
The leaders here know."
And I will explain that shortly.
A girl South African girl in school said,
"Even my friend told me she won't eat with
me again.
One told my right to my face and I've got
AIDS and I should stop coming to school and
I should just stay home.
I would feel terrible.
Cry deep down.
I would sit alone and cry alone."
And that loneliness is a pattern of children
who've been stigmatized.
[pause]
When children when people are afraid and stigmatized,
they do not choose easily to go and get tested
and to follow up with any counseling or medications
that are possible.
And just this morning I read an editorial
in the Kenyan paper of a man talking about
how reluctant he was to get tested until after
actually a child was born.
It isn't something in the past.
It continues.
As a result of all of the pandemic and the
spread and so forth, there have been millions
of orphans to AIDS.
Nearly 15 million children in Sub-Saharan
Africa have lost one or both parents to AIDS.
There are strides and there are more and more
people getting antiretrovirals.
But still across Sub-Saharan Africa less than
half of the people who need to take the antiretrovirals
get them which means the other half will ultimately
die and many of them are in their productive
years of their 20s and 30s and are parents
leaving more orphans.
So we look to a future of more, not fewer
orphans unfortunately.
As children are orphaned, their aunts, their
uncles, their neighbors take them in and poor
families who take in more children with more
mouths to feed become more impoverished.
And these are pictures from Kigali in Rwanda.
The one on the right indicates the poverty
is related and interacts with unclean water
and poor sanitation.
One way to measure the impact of poverty on
children is to look at the number of children
who are underweight.
In 27% of children across Sub-Saharan Africa
are underweight both affected by HIV AIDS
and not.
In Burundi, over half the children are stunted.
It's one of the poorest countries and it's
where we have a project.
I remember the first time I went there when
I met a boy who was about this tall.
And I usually figure an amp can child is older
than I would assume when looking at an American
child.
This boy I assumed conservatively perhaps
14, he was almost 17.
So these children who are stunted, it affects
their physical development.
It also affects their cognitive development.
Gender is, as you probably know, a significant
factor in the HIV AIDS pandemic in Sub-Saharan
Africa.
Fully 60% of those living with HIV in Sub-Saharan
Africa are girls and women.
For young women and girls it's particularly
noticeable.
In South Africa, while 4.5%of young men between
the ages of 15 and 24 are HIV positive, among
the equivalent group of young women the rate
is 13.8.
So if you were a teacher of secondary students
it could be that three of the girls in your
class and one of the boys is infected.
How can that be?
It's very complicated this gender differential.
Studies of childhood behavior show gender
influence behaviors which is of course true
of all societies.
In South Africa where these studies have been
done, people have noted that girls learn very
early to be compliant and boys learn very
early to be assertive.
And those behaviors continue.
And it affects behaviors including sexual
behaviors as adults.
And it isn't just that males believe that
women have no right to refuse sex, which is
the case of 47% of men in Lesotho, but 40%
of women agree to that.
As one South African woman said in a group
context with other women, "I can speak out
here."
She was in a program for empowering women.
"I can speak out here but who will defend
me when I am alone with my husband in the
bedroom?"
Implicit in that statement is the fear of
violence.
And indeed, there is considerable violence.
And I'll tell you an instance in the workshop.
This is the workshop that we did in 2003 sometime
ago.
At a workshop about HIV transmission my husband
and I asked participants to answer whether
or not each situation could result in transmission
from a set we presented.
The audience was made up of teachers and secondary
school students.
About equal numbers of both: men and women,
girls and boys.
Everyone agreed that one could not be infected
through hugging for example.
The place came apart however over one situation.
The man and the women ended up shouting at
each other about this one.
A man goes away to another country for two
months on a special assignment.
When he gets home, he has unprotected sex
with his wife.
Could she become infected?
The women said of course she could.
The men, no she couldn't become infected.
These men and these women had very different
understandings of the meaning of the disease
and their gendered role and talk across these
misunderstandings is critical.
Women are affected in other ways as well.
Many families, many orphans are being brought
up by their grandparents usually the grandmother.
Over 50% of orphans in some countries such
as Kenya are brought up by grandparents.
This is a grandmother and granddaughter in
our projects and they're doing very, very
well.
You can see this is a nice, neat house.
This child is well-cared for.
That is not always the case.
And it certainly isn't the case when great
poverty and great numbers of children.
I heard of a woman in Uganda who was trying
to raise 13 grandchildren.
And here's an observation we made that underlies
the feelings that these grandparents have.
In a church service in a township outside
Johannesburg we watched a young boy about
four years old and his very aged grandmother,
perhaps it was his great grandmother.
She was urging him to walk across to the other
side of the huge room to join a group of other
children and teacher.
It would mean he would have to walk in front
of a huge crowd of people and he was scared.
She kept urging him to go but he was determined
to stay in safety with her.
Finally leaning heavily on a cane, she took
his hand and walked him across to the class.
But we wondered how long that little boy would
have this elderly woman to care for him and
make him feel safe.
Some children and I don't have reliable figures
unfortunately live in child headed households.
And this is a family, the picture was taken
maybe three years ago, perhaps four, three.
Anyway the older girl and her twin sister
at 16 after their mom had died were given
this house.
A little 3-room concrete block house for the
two of them and their two brothers.
They no sooner got in the house than they
got in touch with their two young cousins
who had also lost their mother to come and
live with them.
And that is the African way as families accept
more and more children and try to help them
out.
That little boy, the littlest one next to
the girl with her arm around him was born
when his mother was sick with AIDS.
And I don't know with that particular child
was infected at birth, but many children have
been infected at birth such as this baby.
A great deal of effort has gone into reduce
mother-to-child transmission.
And fewer and fewer children are born infected
which is a very good thing.
In the U.S. and in northern Europe, it's less
than 1% through the, by giving antiretrovirals
to the mother before and during birth and
following up the baby afterwards.
And in some hard to reach places which is
an ongoing issue in Sub-Saharan Africa they
have baby and mother packs that the mother
can go home with after birth because they
are losing a lot of children who live so far
away to keep coming back for testing after
birth.
So a lot of effort and good effort has been
put afoot into saving children's lives.
And indeed treatment has increased a great
deal.
Clinics have gone up.
Antiretrovirals are more and more available.
But your chances if you need antivirals when
you get sick depend somewhat, depend largely
on where you live.
In some countries the claim is that 95% of
the people in Rwanda to be specific, the claim
is that 95% of the people who need antiretrovirals
get them.
In Burundi the other country where we have
projects 27% of people who needed them.
And sadly there are reports that Burundi has
lost some of its grants and people who have
been taking antiretrovirals are dying.
I've seen similar reports of shortages in
newspapers since this came out just in recent
weeks in Malawi and in Zambia and in Uganda,
but theirs may be a problem of distribution.
In any case, it is an ongoing problem and
more to that in a moment.
But this picture, let me tell you about it.
This is, I interviewed a number of children
and I asked them to draw pictures and I have
a few in the book and here is Jean's picture.
This is a time that she was proud of.
And this begins to show how our emphasis has
been to build resilience in children living
in this, very difficult circumstances.
Jean is one of nine children.
Her mother is HIV positive and was receiving
free drugs at the time I talked with Jean.
Her picture is about an earlier time.
In her picture her mother sits with her back
to us.
She's just come from the hospital where she
learned of her HIV status.
And Jean said her mother cried for days.
She asked help from a neighbor, that elegantly
dressed woman on the left who refused to help.
And after several days Jean went to her association
and consulted one of her leaders who told
her more about the disease.
So at the bottom you see the four little stick
figures, that's Jean and three siblings talking
to the figure on the left, the leader.
After learning about HIV AIDS from a meal,
Jean came home and told her mother about how
drugs would keep her alive.
And how all the children would help.
Jean is very proud that she took on the responsibility
of finding out about HIV and helping her mother.
Her mother would live and she, Jean, would
help resolve family problems.
But even in the face of this dire diagnosis,
this child is getting strength to move in
there and help.
Another child, this one herself infected.
[pause] Sorry.
Mary Anthony was 13 when I interviewed her
and a double orphan.
She did several episodes in her picture so
I just pulled this one out.
She said that since she has been taking antiretrovirals
she is no longer sick every day and she shows
the virus leaving her body in the figure above.
The HIV's are the almost human like markings
around the sketched prone figure.
You also see a friend who has come to visit
and is dismayed at her sickness.
Although faulty, it portrays Mary's belief
that the virus is leaving her.
And despite daunting challenging, she goes
to school, she is a very good student and
she participates in a association she belongs
to and looks to a positive future.
But for children like, oh, and I should also
point out in addition to the inequities from
country to country in whether or not people
get antiretrovirals.
Children don't get antiretrovirals at the
same rate as adults.
For a number of reasons like people aren't
attending to older children who are infected.
The availability of antiretrovirals of course
depends on money and in addition to the shortages,
some of the large donors have leveled off
their funds for HIV AIDS.
So we look to a difficult future.
Here's the problem in a nutshell.
On the left, those x's represent 7,000 people
newly infected every day.
On the right are half those who can get on
antiretrovirals in the same period.
And actually, that was before the shortages
began to appear.
So the problem lies in prevention.
I mean, the answer lies in prevention.
Preventing infection in the first place is
the most important part to my mind of facing
the HIV AIDS epidemic.
There are, ultimately, one day we hope there
will be a vaccine.
And there's a great deal of effort for years
to develop a vaccine.
And that will be the final answer.
Unfortunately, the HIV virus is a very wily,
people use that word, wily virus that changes
over time.
So, to grasp it if you will with a vaccine
is an extremely complicated measure.
The development of jells for women to apply
which people had great hopes for then the
research showed problematic results and they
pulled all the studies.
But recently there's been some positive results
from some initial studies that need to be
followed up.
And of course there are condoms.
Condoms are both the technical use and the
behavior change.
I'm going, and to my mind, even if there were
vaccine the years it would take to get it
up and running out to the places in Sub-Saharan
Africa where it's needed would be difficult
to achieve.
So behavior change is essential.
Here you see two young leaders of the associations.
In Africa, it's very common for people of
like interest to form associations.
And in fact, register their associations.
And have them to be official.
It's far more official for example than a
club that we would have here.
And we have, CHABHA has four associations
of children infected by HIV AIDS mostly orphan.
The biggest one and the one we were first
associated with is represented by these two
leaders.
It's called Amahoro which is peace.
The young woman is now the vice president
and the young man president of the association.
They are both orphaned, double orphaned.
They grew up in the association and then they
were elected by the children to be the president
and vice president.
CHABHA holds the associations which CHABHA
support holds workshops to teach youngsters
important things like hygiene, nutrition,
how to grow a garden and so forth but always
HIV prevention.
And I have two observations from two different
workshops on the teaching of HIV prevention
that I want to share with you because they
show you the effective and the ineffective.
So I, the observations from the young man
whom I call Robert here that you see here.
In fact it was the day that that picture was
taken.
I should say that most of these pictures we
have taken on our trips.
Some of the better ones like the cover of
the book by a young photographer who's interned
twice with our project's named Mim Shafer
and I should point that out.
Anyway, this is what I saw that day at Robert's
workshop: 28 older youth and Robert was known
and trusted by all of them.
He stood at the front with dildo and condoms
on the table before him.
He and the participants reviewed the facts
of the disease they had learned in school
in an easy give and take with important information
written on the board.
Then he demonstrated safe use of condoms and
serious questions and discussions followed.
For example, one girl asked whether girls
needed to agree to have sex.
And all agree that girls as well as boys needed
to agree just as they needed to negotiate
about using a condom.
They learned where to find free condoms and
then Robert pointed out that there were ways
to show affection other than intercourse.
It was the most amazing serious talk.
In fact, in the high school the other day,
I began to show that and there were giggles
and so forth.
But as soon as they heard that and realized
that those youngsters at his workshop were
learning about keeping themselves safe, they
really became quite serious.
Here's the other extreme.
A nurse was asked to teach about HIV prevention
to a group of 50 youngsters.
A man of about 45, he stayed at the head of
the classroom, used no artifacts nor presented
any charted information.
He used lecture interspersed with a few questions
mostly about the progression of the disease
which these youngsters having lived with a
parent who died of it, I didn't put that in
the book, didn't need to know.
I wish I had.
He did ask how it's transmitted when one girl
said through sexual intercourse, he agreed.
But then he talked about how blood exchanged
when there's a cut.
And in order to protect themselves, he advised
them not to use sharp tools, not to play with
someone with bloody cuts, and not to touch
someone who is bleeding.
The lesson neither recognized children's familiarity
with AIDS nor provided information on how
to protect themselves.
Despite being a nurse he didn't talk about
sex.
And that is, there are instances of that across
Africa where schools are told they must teach
HIV prevention and they do, but it is very,
very difficult for many to talk about sex.
And, if you don't know and trust the people
in the room, you're not going to ask the questions.
You're not going to get into the details.
Here these youngsters, they know how dangerous
this disease is, and they listen.
It has been a struggle for Africa for programs
in African Governments to teach young people
knowledge about the disease.
Knowledge has to come first then behavior
change.
But just at the level of knowledge for the
most part fewer than half young people in
their teenage years understand about HIV that
have what is called "comprehensive knowledge"
of the disease.
Which means naming two ways that it's transmitted,
naming two ways misconceptions about it and
whether or not you can tell someone's infected
by looking at them.
Pretty low-level understanding of the disease.
In our projects we did a little study and
we found that 89%of them have at least that
level of knowledge.
But of course, having the knowledge is necessary
but not sufficient for preventing.
So here thus this is the question: where lies
the hope?
I explained about the associations.
They are led for the most part by these young
leaders such as you saw.
For children in a very bad situations, sometimes
and often a transformation occurs as it did
with this girl pictured at one of the gatherings.
The association children gather every week
for all kinds of activities.
I had seen this girl the year before.
I'm going to talk about two different times.
The first time I met her she and her sister
lived in a tiny, tiny room.
They had very few objects.
If you go about counting the objects in your
house, it's like my house beyond belief.
They had almost nothing.
Two mats, an empty cooker, one change of clothing
on a rope across the ceiling.
That's pretty much it.
They were not in school and then because they
didn't have money for school.
They were shunned, because their mom had died
of AIDS.
They sometimes got food from neighbors, but
the neighbors did not interact with them.
They were totally alone with nothing to occupy
them.
And then the association brought them in and
they began to participate in the multifaceted
activities.
They went to school.
They got health cards.
They went to workshops.
The leaders visited with them.
And here is what they were like a year later.
About 300 young people were participating
in circle games, singing and running, chasing
one another laughing they had gathered with
others from an association of children for
a two-day workshop on life skills.
They would soon be in a classroom learning
about family, community, and HIV prevention.
I saw several children I knew including two
sisters.
They were transformed from the last time I
seen them, wonderfully transformed.
There they were with arms around other girls,
their friends.
Then after a few minutes they formed a line
and sang a song about AIDS they had written.
It was a plea for cessation of stigma against
children like themselves.
More and more of the hundreds of children
gathered around to listen and as they sang
the girls seemed confident and strong.
And when they finished everyone clapped with
generous knowing appreciation.
And that's the transformation into strength
and resiliency that we have seen.
Hope lies in many things.
It certainly lies in going to school.
And going to school is complicated.
We still do not have universal primary education
though it's been called for since 1934.
And even in countries in several Sub-Saharan
Africa that claim to have universal free primary
education, they don't.
Because the children don't have the money
for shoes, for pencils, for uniforms such
as these children here.
And in many schools even though the government
doesn't approve of it, the schools charge
contributions and chase the children away
if they don't have it.
So getting to school and staying is a very
big problem for these extremely poor children.
And indeed, in Rwanda and Burundi, I just
recently saw these data, about half of the
children make it to fifth grade, half.
They really are working on it.
And it's a matter of land and will and classrooms
and teachers and everything you can imagine.
The story in secondary education is also is
worse because it costs a lot more money.
And in recent years, the price has gone up
and Rwanda.
It's gone up from 200 to 400.
That's a lot of money for poor families.
So in our project we do what we can.
We send as many children to secondary school
as possible but for only a small percentage
of youngsters in a country in secondary school.
The children in the pper middle class, the
elite, going to secondary school means that
that country is not going to progress in terms
of productivity at the rate that's hoped for
at least I would think so.
One option that we have done and many others
have done is to develop vocational education.
And you can see [pause] this boy who's learning
to be a mechanic.
We have other youngsters who've learned to
be cooks, to work in beauty salon, to sew,
to work in hotels and some of them complain
about those being rather low-level skills.
But [pause] often they lead to much more.
Here's an example "I could not go to secondary."
This is a boy who did not want to go in the
program to learn to cook, because that's what
women do.
But he was given the option that or no training.
So he took it and he learned to love it.
"I could not go to secondary school because
I had to support my sisters by working odd
jobs.
Before I was living day-to-day though now
after hard work and completing my program
I have a stable job as a cook.
I have some food now and can even open an
account at a local bank.
Since my sisters are not in school, I'd like
to be able to put them into school or vocational
training.
My mom is sick with HIV so I have no long-term
plans beyond caring for my family."
So that's a success story.
And he became the head cook in the restaurant
where he did his internship.
And now he's the head cook in another restaurant
and doing well.
Not everyone has gotten wonderful jobs like
this, but a number have and we're pleased
with that.
You know, in many of our families certainly
and children have access to the kind of development
that parents give us and libraries and so
forth.
These children have none.
So we really had, it was a wonderful experience
a couple of years ago when we were five of
us coming at one time to Kigali because we
took visitors and each was made to carry heavy
suitcase filled with English language books
and we started what we think is the first
English language little library in Rwanda.
The school language in the first years children
learn in Kenya, Rwanda and the school language
for years and years and years has been French.
Various reasons historical and commercial
they announced that it would change to English
across the board for the whole country.
They gave the teachers their 18 months, which
is a very short time to learn a new language
and to be able to teach in it.
But amazing and the children are just loving
it.
They come and they read the books.
And the boy in the middle of the picture on
the left with the dark book that's the dictionary.
He's just sitting there reading English words
trying to absorb as much English as they can
because they know that's a doorway to a better
future.
Another way that hope comes is when families
are supported.
And we have been able to provide goats for
many families and many families are developing
kitchen gardens to be, have more sustainable.
Health cards are provided for youngsters.
Here are leaders filling out health cards.
There are home visits that are highly valued
by the children.
In the book I of course talk about CHABHA.
I also highlight a program in South Africa
called Isibindi.
And there, the woman with the shirt of the
yellow letters on it is the young leader,
one of many, from the community who's been
trained whose assigned several families and
she visits the family in-depth several times
a week teaching the children how to cook,
how to shop and encouraging them to be able
to take care of themselves.
The CHABHA model which is represented over
here with one of our leaders and children
he's visiting.
That model supports group kinds of activities
more than individual families.
Hope lies in the workshops.
And ultimately hope comes through children's
growing sense of they belong somewhere.
The loneliness that occurs when they are first
orphaned can disappear as they learn that
belong with a group.
They say that about their associations, "It's
like my family."
And the leaders, "They're like my parents."
In societies such as many in Sub-Saharan Africa,
a person's self-worth comes less from who
they are as individuals and more from who
they are in connection with others.
And you probably have heard the term Ubuntu.
I'll read to you Nelson Mandela's words about
Ubuntu because I think it encapsulates what's
happening as these associations work with
the children.
"In Africa we have a concept known as a Ubuntu
based on the recognition that we are only
people because of other people.
We are all human and the HIV AIDS epidemic
affects us all in the end.
If we discard the people who are dying from
AIDS then we can no longer call ourselves
people."
I think Mandela would agree that if we said
we discard the children of people who are
dying from AIDS then we can no longer call
ourselves people.
There are two questions that I want to consider
at this point.
One is whose responsibility is it to care
for these children?
Ultimately of course the responsibility lies
in, with the African governments and agencies
and community organizations.
I believe our role is to help them.
CHABHA is a very small organization helping
grassroots projects in Rwanda and Burundi.
We don't tell them what they need.
We go there and we ask them, "What do you
need?"
And we negotiate that of course.
But ultimately they are the ones who are going
to provide the children the basics they need,
the psycho-social support that they get, and
the ability to grow up for the future and
be resilient.
More and more African governments are urged
to attend to children.
And one report called Budgeting for Children
in Africa by a group scholars in Africa wrote
this, "There are many reasons why Africa should
invest heavily in children first and foremost
because it is the right thing to do.
Because it's the only way Africa can catch
up with the rest of the world.
Because investment in children and youth contributes
to democratic governance and social stability.
And finally because without children society
will die.
So it is about rights, about society, about
economics, about good governance and about
our future place in the world."
And the children affected by HIV AIDS are
the ones who most need to be helped so that
that and be attended to by governments.
Finally, sometimes people ask us and certainly
I know people wonder, "So what's the use of
a small project like CHABHA when the need
is so huge?"
CHABHA supports the projects that work with
somewhat less than 3,000 people.
It's a drop in the budget of nearly 15 million
children.
So, I turn to a story.
Some of you may have heard it.
Do you know the star fish story?
It's kind of a metaphor.
And I changed it.
It's written, a wonderful book, I think I
have pages and pages of footnotes, but it's
the last one, Loren Eiseley, a book called
The Star Thrower.
Anyways there are lots of stories but which
is one I adapted.
"A man walking along the beach one day came
over a dune and saw spread as far as the eye
could see millions of starfish.
Ceaselessly picking starfish up one by one
throwing them into the sea, the man asked
her "Why are you throwing them into the ocean
you'll never be able to get them all?"
And the young woman said "That's true but
the sun is high and the tide is running out
and I can save this one" and she threw another
into the sea, "And this one," and she threw
another one."
So that is a romantic story it has helped
us at times when we wonder our direction.
I have only a short skit of a youngster's
playing in one of their gatherings.
But I think it's appropriate to stop here
and ask for questions or comments or thoughts
that you may have.
[pause] Yes.
>>Audience: [inaudible]
>>Dr. Grannis: Oh, oh, take the microphone.
>>Audience Male #1: Thank you.
Well, you were saying about the impact of
the small organizations and I think that what
I've learned about, I've learned a lot about
the HIV AIDS epidemic and the various issues
from CHABHA's work, following it that you
guys are so close to the ground that you understand
children who do get primary education still
have to bring a wad to have paper to school
so if they don't get chased from school.
So we need to address that problem.
Not obviously in every individual school,
but at the upper level, the government and
then you also need to get UNAIDS involved
and you also need to get human rights involved
in the country.
But you need the on the ground contact to
really understand the impact it's having on
individuals because the large organizations
can't really understand that, but not the
small.
>> Dr. Grannis: Absolutely.
I saw a TV program soon after my last trip
of many to Rwanda and it was Partners in Health.
Have you ever heard of them?
Do wonderful work.
Okay?
I'm not, but they announced that in Rwanda
there's universal primary education.
And I thought, "How do they not know that
that's, it's not universal."
So even a project that is in the country may
not know about children.
Jesse who's speaking was at that first workshop
that I told about when everyone agreed you
couldn't get HIV from hugging and so forth.
And he has since been doing a great deal of
work including work I've written about in
here with HIV prevention in high schools.
And now takes groups of young people to Rwanda.
I don't know if we have time for you to.
His program in high schools is, the youngsters
build their own dramas around real stories
that they know.
And so, it's like the prevention workshop.
It's very person to person.
It isn't some far away story about a disease.
It's what they know and have experienced.
Do you have a question?
>> Audience Male #2: How are these associations
funded and are they cross-tribal or with a
single tribe?
>> Dr. Grannis: Oh my goodness.
Let me deal with the first one.
The large one, the workshop they had formed
from young adults who had lost their parents
both in genocide in Rwanda and from HIV AIDS.
And they were raising their own siblings.
They were the oldest in their families.
And they got together to help one another
and then more and more children came and then,
they formed the associations.
They had no money.
When I first met them in 2004, they had a
tiny little office, maybe three pieces of
paper.
They had some benches and they had an old
desk.
And UNICEF had come and said thank you and
left and not helped and no one gave them any
money.
Because how could such a group write a proposal?
I mean, so we took a risk with them and we've
been working with them ever since.
Another project, the one in [inaudible] in
Nymata outside of Kigali.
I have a quote in here somewhere but I won't
look for it because it'll take too long.
But the leader said, "We have a association.
We work with the children.
We went to the district office and asked them
for money and they didn't give us any.
But then we heard about Eric and CHABHA.
So they called Eric who was our country director
and they called Eric up and Eric went out
there.
Actually let me tell you about that story
in funding.
We're talking about a very little money that
goes a long, long way.
Eric went with the equivalent of $2,000 in
his pocket.
And he had asked the leaders to do certain
things that they needed to do to organize.
He went out and they hadn't done it.
And you know Eric.
He just pulled up the money and put its back
in his pocket and said sorry you're not getting
the money.
This was to get more children in school to
do more health work.
You're not going to get it until you do these
things.
They watched him go away in his funny little
old car.
Then they came back to town within a week
they had done it.
They got the money.
They were a wonderful project too.
They really are.
They do wonderful things with children.
Yeah.
The other question is a very big question
in Rwanda and Burundi both where both Hutu
and Tutsi groups have they experienced genocide.
Rwanda in a very short amount of time and
Burundi over many years.
Nobody in, nobody mentions a person's Tribal
or ethnic identity.
It's really against the law I would say in
Rwanda.
In Burundi I don't know.
I don't hear about it.
I think that as we have found out and I didn't
know this for years, because it's not something
you talk about that most of the children in
the projects are Hutu.
Well, most of the population is Hutu, so that
makes sense.
And some of the leaders are Tutsi.
Not all, by any means.
Isn't that correct would you say?
David Loewenuguth is the Executive Director
of CHABHA.
He spent nearly a year as a volunteer there
and before that.
So he really knows.
>> David: Well, thank you Dr. Susanna.
It was a really wonderful presentation.
The and Jesse could probably answer to this
question a little bit more.
The government of Rwanda is focused on really
transitioning to "We are one.
We are Rwanda." and leaving behind the tribal
history but that they all recognize is going
to take generations to accomplish.
>>Dr. Grannis: It's very complicated about
its Rwanda's moving forward incredible pace
and there are people saying the human rights
problem is something to be concerned about.
How does one that is not part of it know?
I can't claim to, certainly.
So looks like we're finished.
>> Female Audience # 1: Yes [inaudible].
>> Dr. Grannis: Well, this is five minutes
and I don't know if you have five minutes.
It's kind of a silly skit of youngsters and
a gathering with paint on their faces nothing
to do with the skit.
I'll just tell you what it is because you
all have to go back to work, right?
The girl walking in in the jeans is pretending
to be the teacher and the children on the
bench are her students.
And I'll just show you.
They do a little musical number and they get
her to do the music.
And then the principal comes.
And she is very mad then she does the music.
[video plays]
[children talking in video]
You hear their English?
She's telling them how to behave when she
leaves the room, okay?
Let me move it ahead.
Okay.
This is, boy, I went backwards.
She's starts.
Here's the principal.
[children talking in video]
Here's the district superintendent.
Well, that's it.
The
minister of education comes and he's got,
it's Abdul and he's got a suit on.
And he has put a pillow in his stomach and
he's standing there.
And then ultimately he dances too and the
place comes apart.
And one of the leaders turned to me and said
she didn't approve of that at all.
I thought you know when young people run an
association, they know that children should
be having fun.
And the children come to the gatherings have
fun with the leaders.
Anyway, thank you very much.
I'm glad to have been here.
[Applause]
[Inaudible]
>> Announcer: Let me turn this off here.
One second.
Here, great.
Beautiful.
Let me turn the monitor off.